the idea that conspiracies are you know
can't exist is a ridiculous thing I
participated in a worldwide conspiracy
uh to convert the entire world to
Evangelical Christianity and like I said
you don't need micromanage levels you
don't have to imagine some person
sitting at the top twirling their
mustache you know and directing
everybody at every level for this to
happen you just need common attention
you know a common implicit and sometimes
explicit uh recognition that we have
something in common a goal in common
[Music]
this is Jonathan Pedro welcome to the
symbolic world
[Applause]
[Music]
so for those of you who have seen I put
out a video with Mary Harrington talking
about the often mythological Imaging of
conspiracy theory and how we can often
see through some of the you know fairy
tale motifs or some of the story motifs
that you find in the conspiracy theories
to find a nugget hidden behind it which
can help us understand you know what is
happening in the world that it's not
completely arbitrary the way that these
stories show up and how they do manifest
a deep distrust for the authorities and
they also often manifest some aspects of
how that distrust you know based in
actions that the elites or the
governments have on us contain patterns
of Truth in them but I also wanted to be
careful that people don't think that
conspiracies are impossible because
there is a very strange moment right now
in culture where it becomes almost
impossible possible to identify someone
acting against us and as soon as we do
we are accused of being a conspiracy
theory in some ways the word conspiracy
theorist has become a slander that we
we give to anybody who seems to suspect
the official narrative that suspects
what the governments are telling us and
so the word conspiracy theorist has
become a propaganda tool for people in
power to prevent us from noticing when
some of the actions that are being taken
against us don't seem to be in our best
interest let's say we saw a lot of that
happen during the covet era and we're
going to see a lot more of it come
Downstream for us my own prime minister
keeps using the word misinformation
disinformation to basically tag on any
narrative that he disagrees with
politically these are very dangerous
times when we see this happening and so
I just want to point you to my brother
Matthew pejo on Twitter he has been
doing what I can only say is an amazing
job at let's say analyzing and looking
at the mechanisms by which we've come to
think this way and by which we've come
it's been it's it's become impossible
for us to identify when there is you
know let's say when the system is rotten
and when there's action against us when
enemy is acting against us from within
the system uh and he he really breaks it
down so it's very much worth following
him and looking at his different threads
on Twitter
to see how it is that this has captured
us but what I wanted to talk about today
is mostly to help people understand
how you know how conspiracies are are
often around us how we participate in
them and how other people participate in
conspiracies and and that you know
although we do that all the time we are
now told that it is impossible for these
things to exist and so I for example
grew up in an Evangelical Church I grew
up in a Protestant environment and I
participated in what can only be called
a worldwide conspiracy you know in the
churches that I grew up with especially
there was a conspiracy to convert all
human beings on the earth to not only
Christianity but to my very specific uh
version of Christianity and this was
both explicit and implicit within the
structure that I had it was both
centralized and decentralized which
means that there didn't have to be
strict relationships between all the
different churches for that conspiracy
to take effect but we all knew that this
is one of the goals that we had as
churches our own church and churches
that we that we didn't know about and
people that we didn't know about and
sometimes they would manifest itself
centrally that mean that there would be
people in power certain evangelists or
certain pastors that were you know
considered revered or having influence
even though they didn't have a strict
you know uh micromanage relationship it
didn't have to be like a an organization
that is completely organized all the way
through but it was people that had
influence and that we all recognize as
having some kind of authority would give
directions you know how to evangelize
movements and evangelization different
ways of doing it and then that would
trickle down in the churches so that it
would affect our the way that we did our
um our evangelization uh the way that we
recognize how important it was at
different moments with the waves of how
important it was and so this was
something that I participated in and so
the idea that conspiracies are you know
can't exist it's a ridiculous thing I
participated in a worldwide conspiracy
uh to convert the entire world to
Evangelical Christianity and like I said
you don't need micromanage levels you
don't have to imagine some person
sitting at the top twirling their
mustache you know and directing
everybody at every level for this to
happen you just need
common uh attention you know a common
implicit and sometimes explicit uh
recognition that we have something in
common a goal in common and then people
end up helping each other working
together working decentralized and
centralized towards the manifestation of
that of that you know that worldwide
conspiracy and you know and so when we
recognize for example in the Rainbow
Coalition a conspiracy to affect the
world and we're told that that is
impossible and it's ridiculous to state
that
obviously it's a conspiracy of course
it's a conspiracy because it's a
conspiracy of people that are both
centralized and decentralized that
recognize a goal which is to get
everybody to accept their own position
and they act in the world they have
agents in the world you know and so they
they try to infiltrate different
organizations just like Christians do
that too they don't do it out of weird
mischievous uh and like you know
Whispering behind doors you know it's
like
we want people that agree with us to be
part of the institutions around us and
influencing those institutions towards
the goals that we think are important
and that is true of the Rainbow
Coalition and it's true of Islam and
it's true of you know different uh
interest groups in the world and
different organizations that are
sometimes centralized and like I said
sometimes decentralized this year we saw
the Advent of the progress pride flag
and so all of a sudden everywhere in the
world the the pride flag got switched to
this new progress flag and so that is
called The Conspiracy that is a network
of people that have all agreed to do
something in unison
you know this isn't a government this
isn't like people that were elected for
it to happen it was a it was a
concentrated effort
of a of an organ of a of a let's say of
a a series of people related to each
other that all agree to do something in
unison and and it's not like it doesn't
have to be a totally top-down thing
sometimes it can just be everybody knows
where to look and when something changes
in that direction then everybody aligns
themselves with that change without
receiving orders without receiving some
like explicit orders from the top down
all the way to them and so
that is very important to understand and
so we have to be able to break like this
is what matters been trying to help
people do is like to break a kind of
spell on us where we we you know it is
impossible for us to notice that these
patterns of aggression or these these
patterns of organized intention appear
in the world uh because the the media
and the governments are telling us that
as soon as we notice that that it is not
a it that it is a wild conspiracy and so
it's the same with things like the WF or
globalist organizations those globalist
organizations they have a conspiracy
it's called 2030 you know and in 2030
they have goals that they want to reach
and they are organizing people that
agree with them both explicitly and
implicitly in order to bring about those
goals and so you know opportunities any
opportunity is good to bring about that
goal and so people activate themselves
at different levels of this conspiracy
in order for that to happen and so when
we notice it happening in the world then
we call it out and we're told that we're
conspiracy theories theorists this is
just part this is in some ways a weapon
of the conspiracy in order to prevent it
in order to prevent us to to to stand in
the way in order to prevent us from not
wanting it to happen and so we have to
we really have to break that way of
thinking and it's interesting because my
brother mature
for a few years now he's been telling me
are you Jonathan you need to talk about
this you need to talk about this and I
didn't see the the way to do it like I
just didn't see the way to do it and so
he decided to do it on his own to go out
on Twitter and to start breaking down
how this works and and uh it helped me
because I'm like oh this is the way we
can talk about this so that so that it
it makes sense and there is a
relationship ultimately between that and
symbolism because there is another way
in which you can understand that
centralized activity can happen without
what people imagine to be this insanely
detailed top-down agreement on
everything
think about any type of hierarchy you
know the way a hierarchy Works isn't
through this like explicit top-down
thing there is a top-down uh structure
that moves all the way down but in some
ways the people that are at different
levels of the structure they don't
actually have to transparently know what
is completely above them in some ways
what is above them can remain opaque and
all they need is an incentive to do the
thing at the level that they are so
think about a soldier digging trenches
in in uh during a war that show that
Soldier does not need to know what the
General's strategy for winning a certain
fight is you know he has to be vaguely
aware that they that they want to win
the war he has to have like at least
some Direction but he doesn't need to
know all the plans coming down all the
way to to him you know he just needs his
Commander to tell him to dig the
trenches and he just needs enough trust
and enough incentive at his level to do
that so that is also true of any type of
directed centralized you know uh action
in the world people just need to have
Advantage at their level in order to do
that so think about you know a lot of
what people said were the covet during
covet we saw a lot of this type of
action which was that
you know the doctors didn't have to be
part of some crazy conspiracy about
covid in order to implement in order to
implement certain things all they needed
were was to have Advantage at their
level to do it and it was the same with
all the different organizations all the
different companies or whatever it's
like if you are handing out Mass amounts
of money to people who go along with the
the basic narrative then that's all you
need in order for the entire conspiracy
to work you don't need anybody being
completely aware of whatever goals
people have you just need at your level
so if you if you give incentive if you
pay more money to people who have uh uh
for hospitals who declare someone to be
a coveted death
you know and then
obviously then you'll have more covert
death
and you know it doesn't necessarily even
have to be that everybody there is
completely Shifty and and is just trying
to get money for themselves it's just
like an implicit thing that sets that
itself up when you give incentive for
people to do it and this is something
that we experience at all the time and
so let me give you an example in your
life that you experience that I
experience all the time right so
in where I live in Quebec there is a an
implicit thing which is that if you get
a construction worker or a plumber or an
electrician to come to your house to do
some work they will ask you a question
and that question will be would you like
a receipt with this work do you want a
receipt and what that question means is
do you want to pay taxes on the work
that I'm going to do now this will
happen all the time almost every single
person that works in construction or in
these type of manual laborers knows that
that's how it works
so why does it happen well because
there's Advantage for that conspiracy to
exist because if I don't if I say I
don't want uh attack I don't want to pay
taxes then I don't have to pay taxes and
this person will take cash and won't
declare that as his Revenue therefore
will also pay less taxes to the
government ultimately
and so this is something that everybody
does that everybody knows is happening
every police officer every politician
every single person all along the
hierarchy knows that if a construction
worker comes to your house will ask you
would you like would you like to pay
taxes and everybody plays along although
it is completely illegal
right there is this Mass conspiracy to
break the law all of everybody agreeing
to to do it or not to do it and nobody's
snitching on anybody so that there's
this massive illegal activity which
happens all the way through my Society
and so conspiracies obviously exist like
there there it is like Mass so this one
is in centralized like this one isn't
directed it's just an emerging phenomena
but you know all of these possibilities
exist it is possible also to have more
centralized you know directed uh
intention like when I grew up in the
Evangelical churches or like the Rainbow
Coalition is is also doing and other
different types of influences that
people have all of these things are
possible and the caricature of thinking
that conspiracy theories uh are
impossible because you know it's always
this completely
um has to be this like top-down uh
micromanage thing where everybody knows
what their why they're doing what
they're doing from top to bottom that's
a ridiculous thing and it's ridiculous
because nobody acts that way and nobody
nobody you know that that's not how it
works because you know it just happens
that way like here's another example of
a global a global conspiracy theory and
this is going to go against a little bit
the way that I talk about Santa Claus
which is that
every year you know
millions of parents tell their children
that there's a man in a red suit that
flies above their house and is going to
land on the house and bring gifts to the
child
and then not only the parents all the
companies do that every single company
is advert using advertisement you know
talking about this red man in the suit
that flies around and brings gifts to
everybody not only that the government
is involved if your child writes a
letter to Santa Claus and sends it to
the mail then that that letter will you
know will get to the post office and
Santa Claus will answer and send it back
to you
and you know and there isn't an actual
red man who does this this all of these
people from the very from the president
or the prime minister of your country
through the entire you know uh system of
the government all the corporations and
all the families are participating in
this worldwide conspiracy you know to to
tell children that Santa Claus exists
and the answer is yes and the reason is
because Santa Claus exists he doesn't
exist exactly in the way but there's a
principality acting on all of these
levels and making it making it happen
and so that is also true of other types
of conspiracies that is our
principalities acting out in the world
and everybody can participate in them
without having to get a memo from the
secret boss or whatever and like you
know
suspiciously acting you know in secret
so that nobody knows what you're doing
in the way that people imagine like the
Illuminati or the Freemasons or whatever
it's like it's just the way that systems
of intention actually manifest
themselves in the world and so I would
say uh you know it's it's very important
you know on the one hand to to to look
at a lot of the stories that come out I
mean obviously a lot of
you know there are a lot of conspiracy
theories that are just blatantly false
that are and just because some
conspiracy theories are blatantly false
doesn't mean that conspiracies don't
exist that compare conspiracies can't
happen and that governments can't act
against their people and there can't be
faction within governments that act
against with other intentions besides to
serve the people all of these things can
be true at the same time but when we
fall to this weird fear and I felt it
myself because I myself have been I like
I don't want to be called a conspiracy
theorist you know I don't want because
that's like the worst thing you can say
about someone but I think it is in some
ways time to break away from this kind
of simple thinking and to be able to to
rather discern when we're seeing you
know you know concerted action in
different directions and be able to
recognize different agencies working
through the world even if we know that
the people implementing it at the lower
levels don't know what they're doing
that they don't necessarily necessarily
have a vision of the grand scope of
things it doesn't really matter they
only need reason to act at their own
level and that can just be money can
just be Prestige it can just be to to
look right in front of your neighbors
right it can just be uh like social
acceptance there are all kinds of
reasons why conspiracies can happen in
the world and that everybody can
participate them you know uh without
knowing what the end goal is so
that is uh you know a few thoughts on
that because I didn't want I didn't
because in with the discussion with Mary
Harrington we kind of talked about it
more in the fairy tale mythological way
which I think is important to understand
and to see uh but I wanted to be careful
that people didn't think that I was
saying that
therefore therefore conspiracy
impossible it's like no yeah there are
sometimes
necessarily that's just how the world
works there is directed action in
certain
in certain in certain uh directions
sometimes explicit sometimes implicit uh
but we have to be able to recognize it
when we see it so hope this was helpful
thanks for your attention and I will
talk to you very soon